[Music]
well hello they are watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see them what's
making the headlines with the consultant
editor of the daily mail andrew pearce
and
oh he's not there yet but he will be
sued
he's coming i'm sure the associate
editor of the daily mirror kevin mcguire
we've got to put some more money in the
machine have we to to get him up uh no
doubt we will soon so while we're
waiting to the front pages
the financial times leading with the eu
offer on concessions on customs
paperwork and the checking of goods
moving between britain and northern
ireland
let's hope the offer will bring the
lengthy post-brexit deadlock between
brussels and westminster to an end
but the guardian reports that the
european union believes boris johnson
could reject the offer
delhi express says that shoppers are
being urged to buy their christmas
presents early because of the supply
chain crisis get your skates on
the metro carries prince william's
criticism of space tourism of the sort
enjoyed by william shatner he insists
the future of the planet should be a
bigger priority
yorkshire post calls on the north
yorkshire police and crime commissioner
philip alex to resign after he said in
an interview that murder victim sarah
everard should not have submitted to the
false arrest by her killer a serving
police officer
the star has more on the war of words
between support mccartney and some mick
jagger the headline hey feud oh i nearly
sang that i'm sorry
and the son has a stream back strictly
come dancing contestant robert webb
heart op web quits strictly the paper
says
well they're both here what a relief
andrew pearson kevin mcguire come on
come on next time
um so well let's kevin let's start with
you um financial times uh straight to
the european concessions uh on northern
ireland and brexit uh will it do the
trick and has it surprised people uh the
extent of it do you think
yeah as as the financial time says the
eu offers to scrap most northern ireland
checks to resolve the brexit standoff
uh paperwork uh uh halved 80 percent of
animal and plant uh products going into
northern ireland from great britain and
it wouldn't wouldn't be checked so it's
much wider than was uh anticipated so
you could you could say it's generous
but the the question will it be accepted
well
we don't know the the uk government says
it wants to go into intensive
negotiations but dominic cummings the
prime minister's former chief aide now
uh dagger's drawn it's got to be said
with boris johnson said well they always
intended to uh basically break the deal
they made so there's very bad faith in
in all of this uh david frost lord frost
uh who andrew if he was european would
call uh an unelected bureaucrat or
something he'd probably run him down uh
is is always uh top thumping but he has
said he's got no red lines uh on on this
occasion so it is possible the deal
might be done the the triggering of
article 16 which would uh allow
uh the uk government certain
circumstances to tear up the agreement
well that hasn't happened but that there
is something of a standoff but it's got
to be said that marisa
the eu commissioner has made a bigger
offer than was expected yes the european
commission vice president saying you
know this is not the day for red lines
or deadlines didn't he um but you know
big offer eighty percent of checks and
animal and plant-based products and half
the customs paper paperwork would go i
am fascinated and it might just be me to
be fair uh why the eu eu bloc has come
to this are they just bored of brexit
and this is one of the big hangovers is
it because maharashevic visited belfast
and actually genuinely spoke to people
about the impact of it or is it the um
the playing hardball of lord frost and
co
andrew i think it's a bit of all of it
and it's actually a hugely significant
victory for frost because only a few
weeks ago the european union was saying
absolutely that the northern ireland
protocol was not for negotiation it
would not be up for renegotiation mrs
merkel said it that dreadful french
president said it too uh and it's been
torn apart uh 80 we were being briefed
this morning we thought it would be 50
of uh the regulations would be swept
away now it's 80
the fact is the eu were bombarding that
border with more regulations more
restrictions than any other part of the
continent of europe up to some
suggestions 40 50
it was like a punishment beating because
of brexit and what they realized was
this is going to cause real damage to
the irish economy big damage to the
irish economy because ireland does an
awful lot of business with the uk that
was a problem uh and um and and it's and
and britain would then be able to say if
the northern ireland peace agreement got
into difficulty it was their fault so
they backed off they've blinked first
the big sticking point though is the
european court of justice will britain
allow the the european court to continue
to police any agreements what britain's
pressing for is some form of
international arbitration but the
european court is an act of faith almost
it's one of the uh cornerstones of the
european union's uh uh regime so i can't
see
i think that would be a red line for the
european union uh and i know that if you
talk to northern ireland traders
probably if you talk to the eu they say
the european court is the red line for
them but traders would not say so so i
think if they can get around the
european court issue it's a great deal
and um
and i just don't see why it's taken the
european union quite so long to to um
pull their finger out and stop being so
petty uh and bureaucratic and
frankly uh vindictive which is what they
were doing on the border hang on in the
months before hang on hang on hang on
the eu has shown more flexibility than
the uh the uk government let's not
forget that brexit deal and the protocol
were negotiated by boris johnson and
david frost lord frost who hailed it as
an excellent agreement and frost said he
was proud to lead the team that
negotiated it now either they haven't a
clue what they were negotiating or as
dominic cummings has said they always
just intended to to break it to say
their their word was not their bond they
would not honor the agreement so
andrew can go on and on about it but the
people who are doing the most
complaining are those who moved the
border down into the irish sea and
johnson and frost betrayed the ulster
unionists uh and the democratic unions
who they led up the the garden path so
you can hang on about great great
victories but let's never forget who
signed and negotiated that agreement for
the uk government
i'm incredibly happy with the outcome i
think it's fantastic the eu has blinked
they've backed down absolutely hugely
they've made a huge compromise when from
just a few weeks ago they were saying
absolutely no prospect whatsoever of a
renegotiation of the protocol well they
backed down 100 lord frost has proved
himself to be a very adept negotiator
he's a tough guy i wish he'd been
involved in the negotiations right from
the start because we would we would have
got out of the european union a lot
sooner a lot quicker
i think he's
you're the um breaker
hang on hang on hang on
you were saying he's unelected if
there's many there's a long history of
peers of the realm taking a key role in
negotiations lord carrington significant
uh diplomat and uh he was in the house
of lords so forever
you forever go on about people you
accuse of being unelected in the
european union and then you defend the
unelected in the uk come on you can't
have it both ways later yeah no problem
guys we've got a lot of other things to
pack in if you don't mind uh we will
wait and see what happens as those
intensive talks begin uh obviously mary
shefkovich the
eu brexit commissioner is already here
uh waiting for those meetings so we'll
keep an eye on that uh in the meantime
andrew your paper the daily mail a male
campaign triumph this is day two of it i
think probably isn't it anyway the new
face-to-face revolution sajid javid
launching a revolution in gp access
family doctors will be offered an extra
250 million
pounds to improve patient access tell us
about this one
well this has been a male campaign for
four weeks because
it became quite clear in large parts of
the country it's very very difficult to
have a face-to-face appointment with
your gp
now
in many parts of the country under under
57 about 57 of appointments are
face-to-face in some parts it's below 50
percent now the gps are saying it's
because of the workload uh caused by the
pandemic and the backlog and they say
they're doing seeing more people but it
isn't the same having a telephone
consultation it is not the same having a
zoom consultation people
not everybody needs to see the gp
face-to-face but a lot of people do and
that the mail has uncovered all sorts of
evidence of uh diagnosis not being done
properly by gps who work very hard and
i'm not criticizing they work incredibly
hard and long hours but not doing the
proper diagnosis because they didn't see
a patient face to face there's also been
a big problem too anna with continuity
people don't see the same gp
and you do need to see the same gp on a
regular basis because they know what you
look like they know about your weight
they can just to tell tell so what the
statue javid has done in the space of
the month found money to pay doctors uh
but they've got to deliver there will be
lead tables published for those who do
not see patients face to face uh and i
think this is a real victory for
patients it's it's gonna make a
considerable improvement to the nhs
because you want uh but the best form of
medicine is preventative medicine so if
gps can spot things early on that only
not only uh makes life much better for
the patient it's going to save the nhs
an awful lot of money i mean it's like
the olden days having your own gp that
that's been gone for years hasn't it but
the difficulty is just very quickly on
this that having you know very roughly
30 000 cases a day gps need to keep
themselves safe they need to make sure
they don't get covered still because
then they'd be off work for 10 days so
there is a there's a definite balance to
be had here it's not all about
exposing yourself and seeing people face
to
face but what about notice
what about dentists they've been they've
been they they mean they dig deep into
people's mouths covered and they're
right close up to them they've been
working face to face right from since
the lockdown was lifted
yeah but there was a long period
dentists weren't uh working and there's
somebody who unfortunately had to use
dentists i know the precautions they
they have now both in in waiting rooms
and when you go into the dentist's chair
so i think they're not treating patients
at the pace uh that they were i think
before lockdown about eighty percent of
patients were say uh seen by gps
face-to-face it's down at about uh sixty
percent now it can go up a bit but not
everybody needs to see face-to-face i
think those who feel they have to and
there will be cases where they should
then that's good but that 250 million
pounds i'd like to see what uh the the
period of time is because in a country
of 60 odd million people that's about
four quid per patient and uh doing my
quick maths it must be about i don't
know 12p a week or something so i'm not
i'm not sure how far it will go and you
can be designated your named gp in a
practice but that gp will probably have
five or six weeks off uh a year so
you'll be seeing other other gps at
certain times and there might be some
that become uh over overworked and then
you'll have to go and see another one so
i just wonder whether that name gp ruse
is just a bit of spin okay lots more
still to come inclu including uh keeping
his feet on terra firma prince william
puts the boot into space tourism as a
mother william goes into space talk
about that in just a moment
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now andrew pearce and
kevin mcguire let's go to the metro
shall we kevin and prince william uh not
impressed with the profound experienced
um experience by william shatner aka
captain kirk
no he's bringing
captain kirk down to earth who'd uh
boldly gone where no old he's gone
before age 90 i got going into space
with jeff bezos but uh prince william is
seen is
just a really a rich man's game and he
says we need some of the world's
greatest brains and minds fixed on
trying to repair the planet not trying
to find the next uh place to go and live
given that bezos richard branson elon
musk they're all into this private uh
space race i just wish they'd all pay
more tax in the here and now rather than
playing these very rich man's games but
no he's uh he's right he's reigned on
shatner's parade and
shatner
90 loved it as it was great and he made
comments about how you can see how
fragile eagle system is i'm not sure
going up in that rocket is going to help
the ecosystem because the amount of uh
of uh of pollution he also shatner said
oh he thinks everybody should do this
well if seven or eight billion people go
up into space like that i'm not sure
it'll be much of an eagle system left
but he talked india about the earth's
atmosphere and it's you know thinner
than the skin and you know looking back
at the blue and the contrast with the
darkness i mean it was it was a it was a
powerful eco message about the
extraordinariness of of planet earth and
if millions of people do see it you know
there is some benefit to that isn't
those you see the pictures inside
looking down i mean it must be and we
know it is mind-blowing for people
yeah it's not an eco yeah i think it's i
think it's a good thing and and
this is much more effective than that
very irritating young young what's her
name greta thornberg
she's so intensely irritating this is
brilliant you can see for yourself uh
the the impact and um and shatner is a
very articulate man and he'll talk a lot
about this in the next few days and by
what the way he looks amazing for 90.
doesn't he
amazing that he stood this bump as well
actually when it landed i was thinking
about
he sprang out of that pod like he was a
teenager yeah i think he's amazing
absolutely and you wanted to talk about
the daily star too haven't got time hey
feud macca says stones are a blues
covers band
jagger says the beatles never did arena
tours anyway there we are uh you can
read that yourself uh 60 years of fist
rivalry who knew i have to confess i did
not but anyway